[Music]
staying at home during a lockdown
with much time to eat and little
movement at the same time
no wonder that many people all over the
world have gained weight during the
pandemic
and while it is quite a stretch from too
much comfort eating to straightforward
gluttony
too much body fat is bad for our health
in fact those additional pounds can
increase our risk of severe illness from
[Music]
covid19
i am overweight and i think i need to
lose
a bit of weight so that in case i get
infected
i'm not in in the danger zone
excess weight has always been a health
risk in times of the coronavirus
pandemic
it could be lethal
[Music]
welcome to our curvy 19 special on dw
news i'm monica jones in berlin good to
have you with us
now then when it rains it pours it's the
perfect idiom for overweight and obese
people these days
they already have enough health worries
as it is
and now a tiny virus is adding to their
plight
putting them into the same risk category
as the elderly and especially vulnerable
dr marcus reiser heads the covid19 unit
here in clinicum fest a hospital
in western germany most of the serious
cases they've seen here during the
pandemic are elderly patients
as well as another high-risk group what
we've seen on our covet unit is that
patients who are overweight
especially those who are morbidly obese
have worse outcomes in this infection
they're more likely to need intensive
care
studies in several countries have shown
a link between excess weight and severe
covid19 outcomes sylvia schaefer
is overweight and she survived the
covid19 infection in early march
first she developed a sudden fever and a
dry cough
a few days later she tested positive
i was in the hospital and they told me i
was a risk patient and that it could end
fatally
two years earlier she had been diagnosed
with diabetes
to get the disease under control she
changed her diet and lost a lot of
weight
she's convinced that helped her to get
through the covid19 infection
relatively easily if covid19 had
appeared a year earlier than it did
i don't think it would have ended that
well for me
with poorly managed diabetes and high
blood pressure
and much more excess weight than now 35
kilograms
i think that would have finished me off
obesity has become a global phenomenon
it's usually expressed using the body
mass index
or bmi which is the ratio of a person's
body weight in kilograms
to the square of their height in meters
a bmi of 20 to 25 is considered a
healthy weight
25 to 30 overweight 30 to 40
is classified as obese with over 40
viewed as severely obese
we don't just have a covet pandemic we
have an obesity pandemic all around the
world and in germany too
at clinic specialized obesity center
martin busing is a bariatric surgeon he
can hardly keep up with the many obese
people seeking
gastric bypass surgery and other weight
loss procedures
in germany their numbers are climbing at
the moment more than 2 million people in
the country
would qualify for this kind of surgery
with a bmi of over
40.
severe obesity goes hand in hand with a
number of other conditions
including diabetes respiratory problems
cardiovascular diseases
dr boozing puts this development mainly
down to poor dietary habits and over
consumption of sugary drinks
what i see again and again in our
overweight patients
is that they simply can't drink plain
unflavored water
soda water or tap water they always need
some kind of sweetener in it
it's developed into a kind of addiction
better prevention can help but when it
comes to that
health systems often fail and the food
industry has a powerful interest in the
nutritional agenda
both these problems explain why the
doctors here continue to battle two
pandemics
covet 19 and obesity
now for more i'm joined by susan jepp
nutrition scientist and professor of
diet and population health at the
university of oxford
good to have you with us let me start
straight away
with the way our report ended it
mentions there that
we're battling two pandemics obesity
and covet 19. would you agree
i absolutely would i mean in the uk
we're facing the incredibly sad
situation that we've had over 70
000 deaths from covert um that's
awful it attracts headlines every single
day
but the fact is that around 60 000
people's deaths are attributable to
obesity
every single year this is uh obesity is
a problem which has been with us for
decades
and shows no sign of going away there is
no vaccine for obesity
right so it has been a big problem
even before the pandemic however now
with the pandemic it seems to be
exacerbated and you've conducted a study
involving seven million people
looking at the connection between
obesity and kobe 19.
what are your findings
well some colleagues have a fantastic
data set
which um draws on data from uh primary
care
health records so electronic health
records so it's all anonymized
but we have so we don't know who these
people are but we do have data
about their weight and about whether
they have had a positive covered test
whether they've been admitted to
hospital and so forth
what we were able to look at was the
relationship between
people's bmi their body mass index a
measure of their weight status
and the likelihood of going into
hospital or being admitted to intensive
care
or dying from covert and what we saw was
that there was a striking association
with these if you like severe outcomes
from covid
in particular admission to intensive
care
so for people with a body mass index of
30 the level that we say
people have clinical obesity actually
your chances of going into intensive
care
are about three times greater than
somebody with a healthy weight
by the time you're 40 it's over six
times higher but the problem the problem
is to a large extent that a lot of
people are not aware
uh uh certainly not aware of their bmi
or that they
are are viewed as adoptees and are
at such risk
well many people might not consider
themselves to perhaps be living with
obesity
but i think many people are aware that
they're a bit heavier than perhaps
is good for their health um the problem
is that we've struggled
to convert that sort of you know general
understanding that awaits a bit of a
problem into a real sense of the need
to act and what perhaps covid has
started to do
is make us really recognize that obesity
isn't just about how we look actually
the really important issue
is the effect it has on our health and
obesity
affects every single organ system of the
body so
we know it leads to more diabetes more
heart disease
many different cancers are increased
people have
problems with their joints there's a
whole raft of ill health that goes with
obesity
so it's perhaps not so very surprising
that this extra
strain that being overweight puts on
your body
also increases your risk from covert now
of course we hear all the time that uh
we have to protect the elderly the
vulnerable but nobody ever talks about
protecting the uh overweight the obese
what can we do about that well we need
to recognize that being severely
overweight
creates real vulnerability and so i
think we need to kind of add these to
our list of people
who need extra take extra care during
the pandemic
all right susan jepp the nutrition
scientist and professor of diet and
population health at the university of
oxford thank you so much
thank you and before you step on your
scale at home now to check if
you've gained a few pounds too many
let's bring in another aspect of this
pandemic
science and its ability to solve
problems
time for your questions and over to our
science correspondent
derek williams
if covet vaccines work could the
research help developers create vaccines
for the common cold
could kova 19 lead to a huge step
forward in this area
i love questions like this because they
don't involve
where we are now which in europe at
least often feels like a pretty dire
place
but instead they look forward to the end
of the pandemic and they ask
whether all the misery might lead to
anything
positive but but while it's possible
that the vast numbers of research
projects being driven by covid19
could lead to breakthroughs in fighting
coronaviruses
as a whole there's still a lot we don't
understand about
how they in general evolve and and how
they're transmitted um
what's called cross-reactivity would
certainly
play a central role in research into any
future
offshoot of vaccines and that's when
the weapons that your immune system
produces to fight one virus
might also work at least to some extent
against other viruses that share
similar characteristics um some experts
believe that cross reactivity from
earlier infections with cold causing
coronaviruses
in some people is influencing how badly
they get covet 19 or
or how easily they fight off the disease
but we still don't know nearly enough
about it one promising avenue for
example that could help
in the development of future coronavirus
vaccines
involves a molecular subunits
in in the spikes those those proteins
that stick out of their surfaces
that allow these viruses to to latch
onto cells
and infect them um researchers have
discovered that some of those
areas look uh well conserved
in all of the coronaviruses that infect
humans um they're
so they're quite similar across the
group um that's a great
starting point for future work but but
it's still just a starting point
so so when you ask whether covid19
could contribute in a big way to
coronavirus research
in general i'd say it already has
but i also don't think that'll
necessarily
be enough to spawn vaccines
in the near term for the coronaviruses
that cause
colds though i'd be happy if that
prediction
proved wrong
you